judges have ruled that a comedian who
mocked a disabled child singer did not
breach his rights to dignity mike ward
hailed the decision by canada's supreme
court as part of a growing backlash
against cancelled culture as both sides
reacted to the ruling
i'm like o.j i won this is the best i'm
so happy i think this is a good sign for
comedy i think this means the the
pendulum is about to swing the other way
comedians are going to be able to keep
on doing jokes i would want to tell him
about how i felt
when i first
heard
the
joke
as a 13 years old to just
think about dying because a 40 year old
men say so that you should die
well singer jeremy gabriel who's now 24
was born with head deformities he found
fame in 2006 and even performed for pope
benedict the 16th but from 2010 ward
began making jokes about his
disabilities gabriel was 13 at the time
and said it made him suicidal and that
he was bullied at school
in 2016 quebec's human rights tribunal
ordered ward to pay the equivalent of 28
000 u.s dollars for breaching gabriel's
dignity and honor but on friday the
supreme court overturned that decision
ruling ward's comedy did not incite the
audience to treat gabriel as subhuman a
ward's lawyer had argued that the jokes
mocked the singer's celebrity status not
his disabilities
okay lined up to talk to about us talk
to us about it now we've got women's
rights activists paula diana we've also
got
comedian ron placone satirical content
creator matt awful all three welcome to
rt good to talk to you first of all i
want to get your initial thoughts on
what you think of this ruling pulling
you first
yeah thank you uh i am really concerned
about this uh ruling because we have to
think about he was a child he was 13
years old so you know as long as you
know um comedy shall be free but he was
a child so we shouldn't treat children
like that um it was appalling what he
said about you know committing
eventually you know our homicide towards
uh towards him uh so i i think he was
disgraceful what the comedy uh you know
the comic did and i i truly believe we
should safeguard our children more
because especially in this case it was
not only a child but it was uh and still
is disabled
uh and and we all know that this you
know people they go through a lot in
their life uh i think he was very very
hard on him and we shouldn't give the
free everything is good you can say
everything because it was a violent
speech so you know there must be a stop
between hatred and comedy between
violence you know and free speech okay
ron as a comedian a victory for the
jester's license i suppose but this is
this really the legal example that the
comedy industry can hold up with its
head held high
well i i think it's a matter of
you know
it's one of those things where
you can certainly say something was in
poor taste
and you can have that thought in your
head both simultaneously saying yes but
should there be legal and financial
consequences uh for a joke and you know
i agree with the court's conclusion i
mean they acknowledged that that this
was a nasty thing that was said
but you know it doesn't go as far as to
you know
have uh legal financial consequences for
this person and there's a reason
this has gone on for 10 years now full
disclaimer i don't live in canada so i'm
not super well versed in canada's free
speech laws um and i'm not a free speech
expert in general but here in the united
states you know we have free speech laws
as they do in canada and whenever there
is a case involving free speech
it is a very thorough process and that's
because it needs to be
free speech is a very precious thing and
one of the um one of the kind of
consequences of having that precious
thing is uh sometimes you have to
put up with things that you might not
like
and you know what kind of what kind of
world would we be living in if all the
sudden you know you can sue comedians
over jokes
one can certainly make the case that
this was in very poor taste
but you know so
when mr ward comes to your town you have
the option to not buy a ticket you can
ignore his podcast you have the right to
do all those things but should he be uh
prosecuted in a court of law
that takes it a bridge way too far in my
opinion
matt
did the law have no room for maneuver on
this it can't necessarily legislate on
subjective uh thoughts of an audience as
to whether something's offensive or
tasteless
i mean i'm offended that this was even
considered i'm offended that a human
rights tribunal
got to charge and and find a guy tens of
thousands of dollars for a joke
comedy and joking
and freedom of speech is a human right
when did this change this is nuts to me
and you know i have to disagree with the
the woman who spoke before uh
this he was not making fun of his
disabilities he was primarily making fun
of people like her
who thought the kid
was so weak
that you couldn't comment and make fun
of his singing and he hardly made fun of
his singing he just said it was a bit
less good than celine dion
uh and the whole joke is that people
were um
said you couldn't joke about him and his
singing because he's so sick and weakly
well no he's not he's totally healthy he
is still alive he the only thing that's
wrong with it is he looks a little
different and he you know he has to wear
a hearing aid okay we shouldn't be
treating people
uh like
so differently i mean have some respect
for the guy he's not some weakling that
you need to defend like let's
paula do you feel that you were the butt
of the joke rather than jeremy thank you
because i'm hearing that's really a
nonsense here so first of all it was
violence verbal violence towards a child
who was 13 years old a disabled child i
don't care if he wasn't addressing his
disability he was disabled he is
disabled of course it's his habits you
know it's his own being you're not
understanding the difference and you
know watching sounds like he's making
fun of
[Music]
okay so please be respectful here okay
so what i'm saying is that you know he
was a child a disabled child he was
suicidal after that and you can't be
free to say whatever you want and be
violent in every way you want in the you
know in your job because i'm an
entrepreneur if tomorrow i treat my
disabled you know employee like that i
will go to court because there are
consequences for every one of us for
what we do in our life okay it's not
only speech it's an action so he was
violent that's violence and you know
what it is that violence man who is not
disabled who was feeling entitled as you
feel entitled to dismiss the poverty you
know and the stress of other people
dude what are you talking about you're
just making all this [ __ ] up we'll do
that this is complete entitlement
when did i miss anyone or anyone's
property please don't use swear words if
you don't mind i want to bring ron in
uh this is tv matt you can't cuss
if it's uh ron if it's uh a joke at the
celebrity status of this boy
he was still a boy he was only 13 and to
joke about trying to kill gabriel by
drowning him
where's the gag there
sure i mean
so first of all
just full disclaimer here that joke was
uh in french a language that i
personally do not speak and in stand-up
comedy context is is everything i mean
that is everything so so it's very hard
to you know kind of weigh in
on a joke that was in a language that i
don't speak but i read the translation
from the bbc and when you read that
translation
again
can you say that the joke was in poor
taste i mean of course you can make that
case absolutely and and people are
totally free to feel that way of course
i mean again free speech does not mean
that there's no consequences for
something you say you can make a joke
and if people don't like it a venue
might not want to book you people might
not want to watch uh you know watch your
comedy online they might not want to
listen to your podcast they might not
want to buy a ticket
that's how it goes
but you know again when when you listen
to or when you read
the the translation of that joke i mean
you would have to at least the way the
law works here in the united states
you would have to be able to make the
case that okay the regular person
applying contemporary community
standards would think that he literally
meant that he actually went out and
tried to do that to this child and when
you read the translation of that joke i
don't see how any reasonable person
would actually think that that's the way
the laws work in the united states okay
well just so you can dislike what he
said all you want that's totally fine i
i don't actually i mean i don't think it
was a very great joke myself
but you know does that mean we go and
and people have to face legal
consequences that's where well sure
just a final fall from each of you you
first matt
so you know the
woman the activist had an issue with um
she's making straw man arguments
nobody's saying there shouldn't be any
consequences ron is completely right
sure people the consequences should be
if people don't like it they can
criticize them and you know don't go to
his show no one's saying there shouldn't
be consequences but the argument is the
consequence should not be you being
fined tens of thousands of dollars and
not be essentially not allowed to
criticize someone and here's the context
of the joke again like i said
the whole joke is everyone was defending
this kid from mild criticized some
criticism about his singing because they
thought he was so weak he was gonna die
in like a month and this guy's saying no
he can't die he says he tried to drown
him he cannot die
he's talking he's saying the kid is so
much stronger than all these people
trying to defend him we'll give him
credit for paula was this just tested
under the wrong law that it shouldn't
necessarily have been questioning a
comedian's right to make jokes about any
subject to an audience uh that's paid to
see them that perhaps there should have
been another law that it went for
bullying child protection something else
i don't know um very well all the laws
you know canadian laws but i can tell
you that i mean this might have been the
right one in fact the first appeal was
successful for the mother and for the
child again we have to give a clear
message to all comics out there you
don't make this horrible joke so with
children don't let the children alone
their children okay and a lot of us
wouldn't you can do that with other
people but not with children and more
than that if they're disabled and ron
well i i just want to say this in
response to that um a lot of comedians
and and i would like to think i'm one of
them it is possible for us to have two
thoughts in our head at the same time
thought number one that's a joke that a
lot of us would never make uh i
personally would never make a joke like
that that's me uh but another thought
that i am also able to have in my head
at the same time
is i can see the dangerous slippery
slope of having legal consequences for
someone who chooses to make such a joke
even if i find it an incredibly poor
taste and um you know free speech is
just a virtue that i think is very
important and without it i certainly
wouldn't have a job and i don't think
you would either so
okay well all three of you certainly uh
the pylons and the uh cancelling it can
be either hardening to a fan base or it
can end some careers i really appreciate
you all three of you joining us on rt
tonight yes and this was not just some
random kid this was a celebrity
okay okay
i think that's everybody cheering this
kid a disservice thank you for having me
i know that you want to thanks for
having me can't do an encourage sorry
you're not on stage but
thanks all three of you all right